awesome well i'm very excited to be here
um and thanks to everybody for
organizing this i'll just go ahead and
get started
so um
yeah the focus of the day will be sports
tracking data specifically really nfl
tracking data and the big data bull um i
listed my twitter there at data with
bliss feel free if there are any
follow-up questions to to contact me
there or and also i just tweeted out
links to
both the kaggle competition the big data
bolt and the code that i will be sharing
today uh so if you want to follow along
as we go it should be easy to do so
so um
first of all what is sports tracking
data why is it important why is it
interesting um
essentially what it is is
we know
a sport like for example in the nfl here
um
we
don't just record maybe what happened
the outcome of the play whether in nba
maybe it's a made basket and baseball
maybe it's a hit in in hockey maybe it's
a pass
we're sort of going a step further and
actually
throughout the entirety of a given play
or series of plays we're looking at the
x y coordinates where the players
actually are and that can give us a lot
more information and this is relatively
new data
a lot of sports analytics um
like
other data sources might go back a
little bit further for example there's
nfl play-by-play data going back to
about 1999.
um but this
tracking data um this this
that sort of gives more information than
just the the what's going on in the play
in terms of the outcome that's actually
giving the the coordinates of every
player throughout the play that this is
relatively new and another thing to note
is it's not typically publicly available
um the mba has a little bit of it
publicly available um
but outside of the big data bowl for for
nfl at least there really isn't any
source that
i know of that that's publicly available
and
the last thing i was going to sort of
say before i move on was
um there's sort of two types of of
tracking data you can use video
uh which
is is used in other leagues such as the
mba and the nhl and soccer um where
maybe you're
you use the same broadcast you see the
video and you um convert the images of
the video into xy coordinates or what
the nfl does is they use rfid chips so
literal radio chips that are going to be
in the shoulder pads of every single
player and in the ball
um that relays to a a sort of a source
uh radio and that will you and it'll
constantly be measuring where the
players are throughout the entirety of
the play so so that's what nfl tracking
data is based on the these radio
coordinates and
that's sort of what we're going to be
discussing today
so next what is the big data bull
so it's it's an online free to sign up
competition i encourage everybody who's
interested after this to look at it
think about signing up um the focus is
on this nfl tracking data that i'm
discussing
and the goal is
we we give
folks the data they have an opportunity
to analyze it create new metrics do fun
stuff visualize it um and
typically um what it also like
as the league we get to see a lot more
cool new content and also as a league
um it sort of provides a pipeline for
nfl team hires and and honestly also
other sports team hires
um it shows
others that you have
this skills to work with this this
complex state and a lot of teams are
sort of asking for this and it's a good
way to show off your skills and provide
new content and create some cool stuff
this is a very very general timeline of
what the big data bull typically is um
typically
the
um oops i'm so sorry
typically the
it starts in september october
um the submission deadline is november
to january uh then there's judging
um the winners are announced and um
we're unsure what will happen this year
with kovid but typically the um winners
have presented in the past um at the nfl
scouting combine february and march and
um eventually
uh the work is submitted into production
uh by teams by the league and um it
becomes useful uh so
yeah currently we're in the middle of
the 2022 big data bowl which launched in
late september and will go through
january so um definitely not too late to
sign up if those are interested
um so here's a quick overview of what
the big data bull um
competitions have looked like in the
past uh we've had three in the past
we're currently in the middle of our
fourth the first big data bull was was
fairly open-ended uh we shared a bunch
of tracking data um and we were asking
folks to look at stuff involving route
combinations
um so sort of how a receiver might run
to try to get open rule changes and
which how the rules the games will be in
their speed um the second one in 2020
what the the focus was expected rushing
yards
um
and i don't know if anyone has seen the
the rush yards over expectation metric
that's something that that stemmed from
the big data bowl i mean last year we
were looking at the secondary and um so
that's defensive players and coverage
trying to prevent um
other players from catching um so so all
three years have been very cool a lot of
very good stuff has come out of each of
them and um so so it's been really fun
so far
um
and i guess the other thing i would like
to note is um
each year we have
more um sort of we have a lot of
entrance we're getting more entrants uh
a lot more attendees it's growing and
we're seeing nfl hires each year
um the first year um we had 11 then
three then seven
um there's a cash prize that goes to the
winner um a lot of countries are
participating for example in 2020 there
were 32 different countries um the
reason 2020 maybe got a little bit more
than the other years is there was this
was sort of a traditional character
competition in the sense that there was
one metric where um other years it was
more open-ended and it was more
submission based and that's that's how
it works this year
um but
yeah
participants we get a lot of
participants and and typically we see
some nfl hires from it
uh so
my final slide is i do this brief
overview um i'm gonna talk about the
2022 big data but that's the one that's
going on today
again september to january and um
essentially what what participants are
asked to submit is a kaggle notebook
that will have uh the
that will show sort of a analysis
results
the goal is to
submit
a paper that gives information that
someone can read
and learn something new and the theme
is nfl special teams plays
uh which
that includes kickoffs field goals punts
as opposed to offensive and defensive
plays um and and also we also are
including some external data which which
comes from pro football focus
um so
this is the first year where we actually
go across three years which is pretty
cool um and there's a lot of cool data
that we're sharing and obviously you can
see on twitter you can see right here we
encourage people to check it out on
kaggle.com
nfl big databall 2022
um
so
with that
i'm going to share a quick animation
of um what this data looks like
and then i think
i'm going to take a quick pause for
questions after i show this animation
before i get into the code
so
um right here we're going to look at a
video
of some data that we could see during
that's included in the nfl big data bowl
um 2022 um it's some tracking data
involving a kickoff play
by the bears and the vikings and i'm
going to show to show
what it what the video looks like and
what the
um actual play looks like so
as you can see
this is before the video starts we we
have some players lined up um
and and they align with the players
lined up there so the players in the
video in white that's the vikings
they're in white here and players in
dark blue which are the bears are here
so i'm gonna play the animation in the
video at the same time and this is just
to give a sense of
really what we're doing is we're just
taking the video we're taking what
actually is happening in the game
and we're just translating it to data to
xy coordinates so we can
analyze um
players in place
so obviously the other planet at the
same time so you can see in the video
it's moving in the ball
um see now the player has the ball and
he's running up the field
and oh the video is not working
sometimes this happens but
um you can see now the the
player with the balls is running towards
the end zone
and you can see that in the video and in
the animation so this is just a a way to
analyze what's actually happening in the
game and we now have xy coordinates um
it just it's a good way to see
how everything is working and it's it's
efficient it's easier than um just
watching every play per se um so with
that i'm gonna do a quick break for
questions and then afterwards i'm gonna
get into the code
thanks so much tom i just took a quick
look at the slido and i don't see any
specific questions on the big data bowl
yet i'm going to check again but feel
free to raise your hand and
[Music]
i can turn on the ability for people to
unmute themselves for a second as well
and we can also
save questions for this until the end as
well yeah yeah that's fine yeah so if
there aren't any questions oh what is
the sampling rate for the data that's a
great question so 10 times a second
we we do a reading so every tenth of a
second
a few one other question was when will
the dateable for 2023 begin
yeah so um
i would assume september october
2022 um
just sort of towards the beginning of
the nfl um season uh um
for the 2022 season
but again i there's still plenty of time
left for for this big data bowl so if
you're interested maybe maybe you you're
gonna be less busy during that time so
that might make more sense but if you're
interested i i highly encourage you to
still try to check it out there's plenty
of time still to get a
um submission
um is the reason why the data isn't yeah
the data is um
the nfl
doesn't want to share the data it's
proprietary part of it is
teams um have access to it and you don't
want to you it just doesn't make sense
to sort of give it away to everybody
outside of this event so
maybe i'm not the best person to answer
that question maybe um
but yeah we don't share it um outside of
big data bowl what is the error um i
don't know if there's like a
met like a like a rmsc i can give you
but
certainly there are some plays where
there is there are mistakes
um sometimes when the ball is punted and
it's high up
um it might lose a little bit of
connection to
the radios that are that are stationary
i don't know if radio is there but it
might be a little bit harder to read
where exactly it is
um so so that that's a possibility of
error typically though for the big data
bull most of the error written plays are
removed so everything should be good i i
guess maybe a better way to what we
could say is i think it's pretty
accurate to
i believe it's
six inches or something it's pretty
close like it's it's at least less than
a foot yeah
um
that seems
yeah so it's less than a foot of air
typically um so so that's this is pretty
good in that regard
awesome
there's a few other questions around
like specific packages that i think
might be helpful to cover maybe after
the next part as well
okay yeah that sounds good so i'll jump
in
to um my code
if no one else has any questions
so
yeah i'm sharing this from kaggle and um
unfortunately i couldn't figure out a
way to make it bigger so hopefully this
is
um readable for everybody um if it's not
i can zoom in but i i'm hoping it's
everyone is able to read it
um
that looks good to me okay good
so
uh
the first code sample i'm gonna do and
this is stuff that i've publicly shared
before we're gonna discuss
um using the big data bull data of 2022
to analyze
kick attempt offset from center
which is a metric that we're creating
and you can only really create with the
tracking data so
the first question is like what what
exactly is this metric so
um as
for as football fans would know um
kickers are part of it is is your field
goal kicker will try to kick a ball in
between the field goal posts
um
as it as you can see in this image right
here
um the goal would be to just to make it
inside and depending on whether it's an
extra point or a field goal it's either
three or one point um that's not
necessarily relevant here
um but
as you try to make it through
as you might as you're if you're kicking
in let's say a soccer ball or a hockey
puck assuming maybe there's no goalie
there but you try to get it as centered
as possible because that would increase
your chance of making it
so what we're doing here is we're going
to measure
how
close the center
as the ball goes to the uprights a
typical field goal kicker might be
and that's just a way for us to say
who's the most accurate who's best at
getting it right in between the posts
maybe there's also an element of luck
maybe one
player might one kicker might be
90 making 90 of their field goals but a
lot of their field goals were barely in
where another player was kicking 89 and
all their their field goals were
completely in
and that just is a way to say maybe
there's a little bit of luck going on
here and in the future we might expect
this other kicker to be doing better so
this is just a way to measure kicker
skill um looking at at that that offset
from center
so um we're gonna load up some libraries
um tidy verse of course um
animate uh we're gonna animate some
stuff and we're gonna make a ridge plot
so
nothing nothing too crazy uh in terms of
packages to start
uh we're gonna load in plays data plays
data that's
you're going to see this in every sport
it's sort of like a description of
what's going on on a given play in
football it's a very
sort of broken up sport in the sense
that you're playing and then you're not
playing and you're not so each of the
each row will represent
um a given play a given series of like a
snap and then what happens after the
snap players again that might be that
you're going to see that in every sport
every sport has players and this is just
who they are so we look at the head of
the players variable and we just have an
id we have their name we have some other
information really we're just going to
look at where we're going to really care
about the id and the name
um or i guess it's the college name but
the id and the the display name which is
their their actual name this is the
plays variable it's
a game idea play id you have quarter
down distance
information like that um
okay cool
so now we're going to load in the
tracking data and the tracking data is
is very big
which makes sense here you have
you're measuring it every tenth of a
second and you have a
row for each player on each tenth of a
second for each play
so it's going to be very large you're
going to there's 11 players per team and
the ball
um so for each 10th of a second you're
going to have 23
and typical plays will last like four to
six seconds so
and there's also some time immediately
after immediately before the play so
it grows really quickly so that's why we
have to load this iteratively because
it's big data so we're gonna load it in
um we're gonna look at the head and as
you can see we have a time we have an x
we have a y coordinate we have an nfl id
which we can match the players and we
have a game id and a play id which can
match the plays and a frame id which is
sort of like
what frame it is you can match it across
um different players on a given play
some of these other variables were we're
not going to use here we might use the
next one s is speed a is acceleration
um so we're
this is what the data we're going to be
working with looks like
so next we're going to think about
cleaning the data
so
um one thing to note is and i'm going to
show you a map of what the data looks
like um we have an x
and a y
and and this is just something that you
this is an nfl field um
the the x coordinate goes from end zone
to end zone the y coordinate goes from
one side of the field across the other
side of the field
um
and this is a way to look at it so zero
zero is the corner of the home end zone
where
zero 120 or sorry 120 zero is the
corner of the visitor end zone so um
football fields 100 yards between the
end zones each end zone is 10 yards each
one thing to note and that's what we're
about to do in the next part of code
um
because each team will change sides
at the end of each quarter
the
sometimes the offense and the kicker
will be kicking in one direction
sometimes they'll be kicking in the
other direction
um so as you can see like
the the x and the y coordinates don't
necessarily change with the
who has the ball which direction they're
going which direction they're kicking
so one thing that it's important to do
is to check the play direction that's
the direction that the team is kicking
um or
in this case in this case kicking or the
direction the offense is going and
flipping it so that way it's consistent
so if you're kicking a field goal you're
never going to be you're always going to
be kicking a field goal the same
direction in the coordinates
so we're flipping it so that way
no matter what the the team will be
kicking this way
that's somewhat arbitrary we could say
they're always kicking this way but just
to keep it consistent we don't want a
field kicker to be kicking towards this
end zone
kicking towards this end zone to look
totally different we want to be able to
compare them apples to apples since
they're essentially the same
um
so we we do that flip
uh we take the tracking data uh we look
at we filter for when the the it's the
football the tracking data also contains
players in this case we only care about
the football although we're interested
in who's kicking it we're not we're
really just curious about the trajectory
not what the kicker is doing it as they
kick it we don't really care about that
um we're taking the football
we're we're looking at the the x
coordinate and we're seeing okay
where we want plays where the lag of x
to play previously and before i let me
note that i'm grouping by the game and
play so that way we're only looking at
specific
for a given game and given play and
we're arranging by the game play and the
frame so that way we're making sure
we're looking in order so we're
filtering for plays where
you're
you have passed the 120 mark but your
previous the previous x was before the
120 mark um so we're really sorry to
look at the map we're really looking
right back here and that's where the
upright is located we're filtering for
the spot right when they cross this back
end zone right when they would be
crossing the uprights
um we're selecting the first occurrence
just in case maybe it rolls after we
don't want any weirdness going on and
then we're calculating the key metric
here which is offset from center so
we're taking the y variable the
crossfield variable
and we're
figuring out the the difference between
it
and the um the center
which
uh
we kind of see as as the goal we want an
ideal kick will be just down the middle
as i might say so
we're taking the difference between
where that y variable is in the center
so then for each game and each play
we're only selecting these variables we
have the offset from center so an ideal
offset from center would be zero
a bad offset from center might be like
10
the the goal posts are about or i think
18 and a half feet apart
all these coordinates are in yards which
is the coordinates of football um so i
think about six point something is the
length of the
uh
the uprights so if you're outside of 3.3
if you're 3.5 and above about you're
you're probably going to be missing the
kick so that that's not good you want to
be making it and you want to be making
it just down the middle
um so we're merging it to the plays
variable we're only looking at plays
when there's a field goal attempt i'm
removing plays when the field goal tempo
is short
um we're looking at the yard from the
end zone just so we have a sense of how
far was this kick we don't want we want
it because if you're kicking very close
if it's an easy kick we we want to treat
that differently than if you're kicking
from a very far distance
um and so we're calculating the kick
length which is the yards from the end
zone plus plus 18 which takes into
account the length of the end zone and
some other factors
um we're joining the players
so that way we have the names we're
joining this this this metric that we
had so now we're only going to look at
what we're interested we're going to
look at the game id the play id
the name of the kicker
how long the kicker the field goal kick
was and what the offset from center is
and that's the outcome variable so
we know that
yeah kicking a 50-yard field goal over
sticking a 20-yard field goal for those
of you know football those are very
different in difficulty so we want to
make sure when we're looking at this
offset from center variable where we're
being fair
um so this is what our our final um very
our final thing looks like we have game
id play id we have a display name we
have a kick length we have offset from
center and we have a description of what
happened
okay cool
so before we we sort of get into
visualizing
um and and figuring out who's the best
this metric it's ideal to animate a play
or two
um
so we're going to use this field from
marshall furman's github we're gonna
just select a random play oh i guess
we're selecting to play with the minimum
offset from center to give an example of
this is one where it was
was a really
like a very perfect kick
um and we're joining that to the
tracking just to select that one out um
i i'm not gonna go too deep into all
these sort of colors essentially i'm
setting a lot of colors and widths
uh just so
um to make sure the field looks looks
good um i'm setting the plot titles the
play description which is which is this
variable just sort of saying what
happened
um
and yeah i'm gonna do an animation using
tg plot um and gg field i'm i'm adding a
segment
for the uprights
so i'm going to animate each point and
it's it's going to look similar to what
we saw
um previously what right before i took
uh the first break
we're going to add some points um and
we're going to animate what the the
players look like and the ball as this
this field goal goes in using g on point
and adding some colors and some text for
the jersey numbers
so this is what it looks like
um
so we see
um this is what this was the kick with
the lowest offset from center so the
best in the metric and this is a 50-yard
field goal i think the other one we yeah
so we're looking at 50-yard build goals
only here so
as you can see um the the
the field goal here gets it and if you
look right there it looks perfectly just
down the middle this is
about as in between those uprights as
you can get
so that's what we're saying is is what
we see as an ideal kick
we now can animate um one but instead
look at the max offset from center when
looking at a 50 yard kick so this one
might be the one that had the that was
the worst in terms of
being able to kick it between the
uprights
um
so as you can see this one
wasn't really that close it was a couple
yards out
of the uprights it wasn't made it was
not a good kick
and
as compared to this one that was just
down the middle which was perfect this
one was
not good and i mean another thing you
can think of is if they're going to miss
it you probably feel a little bit more
promised with their performance if
they're missing it just outside this one
that you missed decently outside
okay cool so
we're going to visualize this metric by
kicker so as we saw before we were able
to merge who's kicking on a given play
to this metric
and that way we have a sense of who's
who's doing well in this metric and for
this we'll just look at all kicks
between 30 and 40 yards just because
there's the biggest sample size there
and
we don't again we don't want to use a
kick length that is we don't want to
vary by kick length because maybe some
kickers are just kicking easier field
goals we don't want to give them the
benefit of that out um there so we're
grouping by the display name which is
the name of the kicker um we're we're
limiting for only kickers who have 75
plus attempts we don't want to have a
kicker who had one attempt that was
perfect and
be showing him as a
um as the best when we know that maybe
he wouldn't be as good if he had a
better a bigger sample size so
we're we're grouping by that we're
filtering for a sample size of 75 or
more and then we're calculating the
average offset from center we're going
to gg plot we're doing a bar plot
and we're setting the theme labels
other stuff and and now look at this we
have a plot that will give us
the the kicker average offset from
center
um
ordered from the best kicker
to the worst kicker and
for those of you who know nfl football
it's probably not a surprise that justin
tucker is seen as the best kicker he's
universally seen as probably probably
the best kicker um
today
and and certainly over 2018 to 2020 i
think a lot of people would
say he's probably the best kicker over
that time
um the worst kicker is is adam
binatarian although he historically was
a very good kicker um
his 2019 season and his 2018 season i
think his last two were probably not his
best
um so that's why
he might be not as high in this metric
compared to some others so
again we can compare and
all the on average they're all making
them and that makes sense because
typical kicker today is probably making
80 90
um
and it because if it was greater than
three maybe we could say maybe on
average they're missing but on average
it's
it's in between the uprights but they
vary in terms of how um
close to right down the middle they are
and tucker unsurprisingly is the best
um and then you see a lot sort of in the
middle he's the best by a wide margin
which also would agree with um intuition
we're going to take this exact same data
and look at it as a ridge plot as a
series of density plots
that will give us a little bit more
information as opposed to a bar which is
just one average we can see
maybe it's maybe
some kickers are just wild they're
sometimes very good sometimes very bad
so they look average maybe some kickers
are
just
typically
right at a certain range and looking at
a density plot will give us a sense of
whether this is a a consistent
a kicker that consistently is at where
it's at or or maybe he
is sometimes as right on the money
sometimes is a little bit off
so
um we're going to
use geom density ridges from the gigi
ridges package
um to to plot this
and again i ordered the exact same way
by smallest average but yet tucker we
can see it is fairly consistent and adam
benatari
um
he probably has one of the flattest
distributions sometimes he was really
good sometimes he was really bad um and
and that sort of agrees with what we we
saw in 2019 he wasn't very good at all
2018 he was decent
um so so this is the the first
um
code that i'm going to share the second
one
i might go through a little bit quicker
but maybe maybe i might stop for
questions here
but also we can people can ask at the
end again so does anyone have any
questions
i can start with um
reading a few from from slido and just a
reminder if if you don't mind if you're
putting questions in the zoom chat i
love to see them there too i just want
to make sure i don't miss any if you
don't mind copying them over to slido
um
but one of the questions
is what are some preferred packages for
best dealing with xy data
yeah um so
i mean i typically
just use the tidy verse
metrics but i definitely know that there
are some that are pretty good i know ben
baldwin has a package and i can't think
of it off the top of my head but he has
a as a package that that does um some
data cleaning for
uh next-gen stats data such as what you
might see in the big data bowl um that's
something i would suggest
um
to just start but i mean there's a lot
of different ways to tackle it
it really depends on what you're doing
and there are some spatial packages that
sometimes would make sense if you're
doing a
specific thing but
um sometimes uh typically what i i do is
i i just can use tidy verse and
um i i guess i would also recommend some
animation packages such as gg animate
just because with this data um it's hard
to just even know what's going on even
if you're
looking at i like to use view sometimes
just look at what data i'm dealing with
um
even that sometimes is really difficult
because there's so much going on
so always animating the using some sort
of animation factors to animate the data
goes leaps and bounds in terms of
understanding what's going on
awesome um one other question is what
insights are you most interested in with
this year's competition
you know that that's that's a great
question i don't know if there's
obviously the theme is special teams
um the the advice i would give is not
necessarily any specific insight but if
you're going to do an insight um
if you're going to participate i would
suggest rather than trying to solve 10
problems at once and say here's a metric
that looks at hunters on punt plays and
here's another metric that looks at
field goal kickers and here's another
play that looks like kickoff here's a pl
like a metric that
a bunch of metrics for a bunch of
different things
i would highly suggest
looking at one specific player
and um or one not one specific player
wants to position one specific position
on a specific play type and really
digging deep um definitely
teams
who and and analytic staffers from teams
are going to be the
judges so so those that are the judges
definitely get gain a lot more when it's
something really in depth that solves
one issue rather than trying to solve
special teams
um with tracking data all in one
submission so i would just suggest
um
whatever you do
um and there's plenty of things you can
look at with punting kicking
um honestly even if it seems simple um
that that can go leaps and bounds if
it's done well just just don't
do don't try to tackle every single
problem just find something that you're
interested in and that you can do well
and just tackle that um really really
well
awesome it's okay to ask you oh i'm
sorry go ahead rachel
i just want to check with you tom if
it's okay to ask a few more now
yeah yeah sure are there any specific to
this um
one otherwise i can i can jump to the
next uh
thing which i'll probably go through a
little bit faster
maybe skip the cleaning steps and just
focus on the results
tom there's been quite a bit of
discussion in the chat about the z
coordinate as especially as it relates
to the animation that you created can
you talk a little bit about what's
available what isn't available for that
yeah so there unfortunately we don't
measure the z
coordinate um
with with our tracking data currently
um
and but
i would say there are definitely ways to
figure it out
whether it be looking at the event data
so that there's events that are tagged
like field goal kick field goal make
field goal
miss
or kick off land
that as well as you could use the pff
hang time data to get a sense of when it
landed
um
so i i would say there are certainly
ways to to use
um the to infer the z coordinate you
know the speed you know how long it was
in the air you know where it landed you
can get a sense of what the z coordinate
is using
and i'm a physics person so i like
physics a lot so using kinematics
as
and i think there has been some work on
that maybe in previous big data bulls
but definitely that's something that
could be inferred
using some of the other variables but
unfortunately it's not um
measured on on-site
thank you i see a few people have put
their their name and they asked the
question on slido so i'd love to
like turn the mic over to you to have
you ask those if that's okay
um
amelia i see you asked a question about
different factors
um pertaining to the kicker would you
like to ask that one live
sure um hi
i was just curious if
how you thought about using age as a
factor um in these kickers and how they
perform
you know um
not in this specific analysis but that's
definitely something that
could be explored and maybe especially
although it's only three years um which
maybe isn't a huge sample size of years
this is the first time when we have
multiple years of um data so maybe that
is something to look at but yeah
definitely something that you should you
should think about exploring and you
have the birth dates from the the
players data so so you should you should
feel free to explore that
awesome i brian i see you had a brian
filker had another question as well if i
could pass the mic over to you
yeah of course uh yeah time i was i was
kind of curious on factors such as like
you know wind direction and speed those
are kind of things you're trying to find
like a uniformity you know in setting
the kick direction um different stadium
constructs and how i always think of you
know phil dawson always mentioned with
cleveland browns how he had a special
flag installed so you can see the wind
direction wind speed to factor into his
kicks is that taken into consideration
at all
yeah so so again not for this analysis
um and
this was sort of built to get people
started uh definitely i would highly
suggest if you're gonna look at um
look at that and you're interested in in
weather stuff definitely go for it um
i posted on the kaggle website so so
external data for this competition is is
totally free to use as long as it's
publicly available to everybody for free
um so
i would i would highly encourage you to
seek out weather data i've posted some
on the kaggle site and tweeted some and
it's also on my github
but also there are plenty of other
sources you can use for weather data so
feel free to use it um and and i would
if you are participating in that you
feel you want to use that i would highly
encourage you to do so
thanks
awesome mitch i know you bet you're
monitoring the slido as well and just
wanted to check are there any other
questions you think we should ask now
uh one of the questions was about
statistical modeling techniques and tom
can you maybe i'll just throw my two
cents in here to kind of underscore
something that you said
about finding something particular and
doing it really well so just as what you
just described for instance
didn't necessarily include any sort of
sophisticated
modeling technique it required really
good intuition
understanding of the sport and some
coordinate understanding coordinate
information and you're able to see a
really meaningful
metric as the output so for those of you
who are maybe thinking
this is a mountain of data i want to
apply this super sophisticated modeling
technique
by all means have at it there's you know
there's certainly things to do there but
at the same time really good intuition
and understanding of
the game and uh just some
court understanding coordinate
information you can have some really
meaningful output as well
yeah absolutely absolutely
i would echo that
awesome thanks tom i'll uh
pass it back over to you to continue the
presentation and we'll save the rest for
the end too
perfect perfect
yeah so um i'm probably just going to
skip the the cleaning and the reading
data for the second
thing
but i'll briefly go over what what
the metrics about and talk about the
modeling technique um so another thing
that uh another demo that we put
together we looked at speed on kickoff
plays so
um
the kickoff
special team special teamers are
planned to sprint down the field
um try to
kick off to
the end zone and try to make a tackle um
and they try to run as fast as possible
to prevent the the return team from from
gain yards
uh so
for those of you know football you know
the kickoff so essentially
uh when the
the the
kicker kicks it off
all the other members of the
the kickoff team are sprinting as fast
as possible one thing that we can look
at is what is their speed how fast do
they go
on these plays
um so
i'm gonna skip the the cleaning and the
reading although those are very
important just sort of talking about a
type of type of model that uh we like to
use at the league and it's also just
something that applies here
so essentially we
assume the data has already been cleaned
uh basically what we have is we have a
game id a play id an nfl id um so a
given player on the kickoff team and
their max speed during the play and
we're gonna try to model that
um and also we we also have surface
which were which we merged which is also
part of it
so
uh we we're going to create a mixed
effects model and a mixed effects model
sort of to account for
lack of independence
among observations
we assume that each player is sort of
from the same population of players and
no player is going to be drastically
faster than another
so we we assume that each player is from
a distribution and
as they um sprint more
uh as we get more observations we sort
of have more of a posterior and can
assume where that player might be
if they have a few observations we
assume they're they're probably close to
the overall league mean in terms of
speed so
we're just modeling the max speed taking
into account the nfl id and the service
um
so
again i'll try to go a little bit
quickly through this
we have a model that takes into account
we assume players are a random effect
meaning
if we have a lot of information about
them we're gonna sort of believe what
they what what the information says
otherwise if they have one observation
we're gonna assume that they're probably
closer to the mean and that's just to
prevent a player with one really good
observation to be
leaps and bounds better than a player
with very few and
if we were to do a a sort of a dummy
variable or a factor
variable for for each nfl id we just
we'd probably overfit and have a ton of
variables so this is just a way to have
sort of a value for each nfl idea and
not over fit
so we're going to look at the summary of
the model
um
we we have fixed effects which are the
surface that's a pretty typical thing um
that treats us sort of like a normal
factor type variable
um and then we have the nfl id which is
the the intercept
um that that's again
we're assuming it's from a
population
um where where all the players from the
population are more or less the same and
will have more or less the same speed
um
we can
plot the
the the results the model sort of the
player effects and again
this is just to take into account um the
fact that
uh the players will will have a max
speed effect
um
that is
based on the fact that they're they're
running across different surfaces um and
that's another advantage of it and i'm
realizing i'll explain this well the
each player will have an effect that
is based upon how they've done across
different surfaces but this modeling
technique takes into account
um each surface so perhaps
it's really hard to run fast on grass
um
players that run fast on grass will have
an adjustment to their um
coefficient it's kind of like any other
model where your each
uh sort of variable will take each other
into account in order to have a
a value that that makes sense so
um
what we get based on taking into account
the surface
figuring out what the effect or the
intercept will be for each nfl id from
in terms of figuring out what their max
speed will be
uh we have
player effects that
can kind of be thought of as
plus or minus
what you might expect compared to the
average player on
the average surface
so
the the thought is matt cole
will typically be about
1.8
yards per second faster than the average
kickoff coverage player on the average
surface um this is the top 25 of the
of all the players in this effect so y
axis player name x axis is that plus or
minus player effect and we have the top
25 in this metric so matt cole
is the fastest or devin duvernay is um
the slowest of the top 25 but he's still
in the top 25.
um so this is just a way for us to
take into account surface and and really
measure what we ex how well we expect
these players to do compared to the
average player
um
this is the this is what the the entire
population looks like of these player
effects so
it's a
left skewed distribution um with mean
zero
um standard deviation around one um
and
uh
maybe actually more like around point
five
um and
the
distribution will will give us
information on what what the this what
this looks like and you can see that the
difference between the best play and the
worst player isn't necessarily that
large it's about two yards per second
um the last thing that i'm going to sort
of touch with this
part of the presentation
is one thing that i would highly suggest
people do if they are
planning on participating in the big
data bowl is to analyze a model
stability to make sure that
okay if this model predicts well for
the first season how will it do in the
second season and or if this model
predicts well for the beginning of the
season how old we'll do for the end of
the season we don't want to
it's a way to make sure that your
results are making sense and are picking
up on something
so
one thing that we can do here is we can
do the exact same process before to get
the
player effects but do one model that is
only weeks one to eight
do another model that is only weeks nine
to 17 and and again we have the nfl id
the display name and their effect enough
id display name and effect so we have
two different models
only using subsets of the data
and
we can merge them together
and compare them using
a a sort of an xy plot this red line is
is y equals one so if everything
perfectly goes through those that line
then that means we have
a perfect fit
um if everything
if anything is a little bit off
um
then then
we're not getting a perfect fit
um
basically based on the fact that
we sort of see obviously trade flowers
here at the bottom seems a little bit
off
um basically since we're seeing a pretty
good fit line we feel pretty confident
um
and then we can do that we can remove
the outliers and feel a little bit
better um
yeah so
then we can look at the r squared
um but
yeah this is just two things that i i
would say to take away from this part is
just one really analyzing stability is a
good way to make sure your model is
is doing what you what you hope it does
and and two um definitely there's a lot
of different modeling techniques to look
at here
um and
definitely take into account if you're
gonna do something
with a bunch of players
um
doing a model with 300 different players
each having their own variable can be
difficult especially because each of
them are gonna have different number of
observations they'll be playing
different number of plays they'll have
different roles they'll be on different
teams so so really um thinking about
that stuff is important
um so yeah i'll pause again and i i
understand i probably went through this
section a little bit fast so
hopefully people were able to get catch
stuff but i'll pause again and i can
answer some questions i i can answer
through
1 15. hopefully i won't get kicked out
of the room that i'm in and if i do i'll
just have to um turn off video for a
second and i can jump back into
answering questions
thank you so much tom that's awesome and
yeah no worries if you have to turn off
video and run to another room thank you
for taking the extra time
um i see there's a anonymous question
that
um you may have touched i think you
touched upon this one already is
environmental data included or allowed
in this big data bowl
yeah it's not necessarily included with
what we're providing but it's certainly
allowed as long as it's publicly
available free-to-all
um so so definitely allowed if you can
find something that you want to use
awesome
um josh goldberg i see you had asked a
question in slido um around peak age
would you want to ask that question live
or add any other any context sure um i
think amelia kind of had a similar
question to it before but i was just
curious if you had looked into any of
the um kind of distribution for how the
uh the metric offset by center what that
looks like for players over the course
of their career if that kind of is a
this is a certain peak age to when
players are you know have the lowest
absolute value there kind of what that
looks like
yeah no um i have not but really i would
just say that that's a great big
dateable project if somebody wants to
take
uh what what i was doing there and take
it a step further um we really like like
that only the data we provided was 2018
to 20 but honestly that's essentially
all the data that we at the league have
because that's when it was it was really
being recorded
so
um realistically
no i don't probably
the the coolest thing about this data is
um answering questions because it's so
new you might be one of the first people
if not the first people person to answer
that question so uh no um i didn't look
at it in this analysis but i would
highly recommend anyone who's interested
in the big data to look at that because
i think that'd be a cool project
that's great thank you
uh let's see going over to slido for the
xy coordinators how does it work with
with sidelines and zach i see you've
actually asked this question if you want
to jump in and add some context there
all right
yeah i was looking mainly looking at
kick returns and punt returns
and of course quite often they run it
over to the sideline i see that it
starts with zero and zero on the home
side line and regime just goes into
negative coordinates yeah that's exactly
right so if you're a returner and you
run out if this mouse is the returner
and you're running out right here you're
probably gonna be around like negative
one negative two and then if you go
above it you're gonna be above 53 and a
third which is is where the
um field ends it'll just be above 53 and
a third and if you're out of your own
end zone you'll be negative and if
you're above 120 you'll be above 120.
perfect thank you very much
yup
absolutely
thank you and i see a few people had
asked questions about where
the data is and also how to access the
code and mitch had shared the link in
the chat window
so you can access that there yeah
and and i tweeted out the code that i
shared as well as the link to the big
data bowl
for my twitter at data with bliss so
feel free to go on there and
all those links are going to be
available and yes you can also just
google kaggle big data bold 2022 all of
this will show up
awesome um there's a
a broad question as well which i think
is is awesome
to ask all of our speakers but they
asked what is the best advice or courses
for someone who has little understanding
and r to develop better skills
and everybody in the audience feel free
to share examples in the chat as well
but i'll ask you this first time yeah uh
so i would say
a lot of how i learned r was just um
i did a lot of learning sort of by doing
and
maybe that hopefully that that helps the
question maybe that doesn't answer the
question completely because i
don't know if i have a specific tutorial
or anything that i
lent on
but essentially i i think the first
thing i've ever done in r it was a class
i took an undergrad um and um it was
i just you could do a project kind of in
whatever you wanted and i just said oh
i'm interested in looking at something
in basketball i'm interested in
basketball um i'm gonna just do
something and um if you do something
that you're interested in with with r or
um the more you do it
it's gonna be easier for you to keep at
it because you're gonna be interested in
the results you're going to be
interested in the project
and um then
um by the end you're going to get a
little bit better and if you you keep
doing stuff like that that's interesting
to you eventually you're going to get
very comfortable with it and it's not
easy i i definitely didn't learn r
overnight and
all this code took
i mean i think i've probably been using
it for maybe five six years now all of
it took like a lot of practice
uh but anyone can can get there as long
as they keep added and keep practicing
and
keep getting better
awesome thank you and i was just adding
into the chat as well i'd see a few
people are sharing really helpful links
also on the r for data science
online learning community i just put
this
the slack link to join
we do have a sports analytics channel
there which could be a great place for
people to connect after the fact as well
and like share resources there too
um amelia i see you have an another
question that's been upvoted a bit as
well can i have you asked that one live
too
sure um so i was just curious if you
took into account like the number of
starts a player had like on a kickoff
return for example and how
um
that went into account in in your model
and the accuracy of it
yeah um again i mean this was kind of a
bit of a simplification sort of a quick
thing
um and i would
maybe i'll send like a broken record i
would just i would say that like i have
not and i think that's something that
would be interesting to look at so
definitely if you're thinking about a
big datable submission including
trying that with with your model um or
building off of what i did here and
adding that is definitely something to
think about
awesome
steven hill i see
that you had asked a question in the
zoom chat earlier on vertical
positioning data
do you want to jump in and add some
context there
sure i think um
i think tom might have addressed that
but definitely would be great to have
vertical positioning data but you know i
think you mentioned that you didn't have
it but it might be able to be inferred
yeah that's what i would say and
honestly i guess how i would suggest
doing it is
um there's an event tagging of
when a kickoff or when a punt was what
like occurred or when a field goal was
kicked
um and even if you can't if the event
tag is off you can kind of infer based
on when you see the ball start to move
in a given direction
i would use that combined with that pff
hang time variable
and you can figure out how long it was
in the air
um
and
let me think maybe you can and and
if you don't even maybe you can just do
it using the hang time variable and kind
of yeah you can actually just use the
hang time variable in kinematics to get
a sense of what the z coordinate is uh
because
and not to get too physics c here but
we can assume that gravity is constant
and you can
figure out if it's in the air for this
long and then it will feel a constant
acceleration of gravity
um then eventually
it will
like like you you can figure out like if
it was in the air for this long you know
what gravity is you know it had to have
reached this z height
and then you can tie that to the time
and then once you tied to the time you
can you can get an x and a y so
um i would i would google kinematics and
there's a way to infer doing that
great thank you
i am i see a few people that also asked
her about where the recording will be
shared so i just shared a few helpful
links there we do have tomorrow off at
our studio but i'll share the recording
by friday afternoon to the rstudio
youtube
and i put the link there in the chat
and then also on the meetup page and and
on linkedin too
um tom are you getting kicked out yet
i
don't think so so yeah
okay
awesome there's a anonymous question
that was was positioning of cameras on
the field for video capture an important
factor for this yeah so
as i might have said at the beginning
there are several leagues including nba
nhl i think and um
soccer that use video tracking data um
the nfl isn't one of them um it's based
off chips that are located in the
shoulder pads of each player and in the
ball so camera angles what was not a
factor um in this at all it's more based
on
a real like a a signal from the chips to
[Music]
the
processor
great thank you
and i see a few more questions are
coming in on the zoom chat as well i'm
trying my best just to organize them
from the slido
but feel free to
raise your hand if there's a question
i've missed and you want to ask live too
i was going to say someone asked if
stadium nets are standard the question
is yes they are
but sorry go ahead
okay perfect um
the other question anonymous question
was how does hang time work with on-site
kick-offs is there any description or
data around the type of role bounce of
on-side kicks
yeah let me let me try to think so in
the pff data
i would suggest looking at kick contact
type for on-site kicks
i don't know again pff is
i don't know the data that data
like that like as well maybe as i know
the tracking data but i would check that
um i'm pretty sure the hang time would
just be how long until i think the
definition is it's how long and once the
ball goes into the air how long until it
touches the ground
obviously as some would know with onsite
kick sometimes you will kick it in the
air and then have it land and then
bounce so that the hang time will be
rather low
um so in that sense it might be a little
bit difficult to figure out exactly
what's going on with like the z
coordinate on on side kicks assuming it
it um
if there is a bounce
um but um i would try look at kick
contact type
um
in addition to yeah hang time and kick
contact type are probably your best bet
but i admittedly it might be
information that's hard to get
thanks tom
i see there's also some conversation
going on in the chat
around williams or wilbert's question
around what are good free nfl data sets
that are available to the public and can
be used
um absolutely yeah
yeah yeah so um nfl faster um is a
package that has a lot of really good
free data sets and i think a lot of
questions i think i might have seen on
twitter and the kaggle discussion page
before we're like oh
how do we figure out who the fumbling
player is how do we do that how do we
and and honestly i would i would just
suggest using nfl faster and
they merge very easily to the data that
we're providing merge on game id and
play id
so that that's something i would
recommend
um
i would recommend i mean the weather
data that i provided also you can use
with gamete and play idea if that's of
interest
um
yeah i think those would probably be the
main two but um there are
tons of stuff out there and the other
package that ben baldwin wrote i think
could also be helpful
wonderful
i think we've made it to the end of the
slido questions
but i just want to do a
double check from the slack here and i
see
matthew you asked is there a way to
access the chat transcript after the
meeting
i will go through that and then copy it
the links and i'll share that in the
youtube recording
and then in the um like on the meetup
discussion page too
um i'm not sure if anybody some i'm
allowed to download the chat you might
be able to if you see three dots you can
press save
might just only be available to me and
uh tom mock i think said something i i
would definitely agree looking at nfl
reader um
i should i think nfl faster than nfl
reader are connected but i would
absolutely recommend looking at nfl
reader um too because nfl faster i think
is better for
live data but yeah nfl reader
also is a good one
awesome
it's gonna open it up if anybody wants
to raise their hand and ask a question
if i've unfortunately missed something
from
earlier
or if you have a new question you'd like
to ask before we end today
i've got a question if it's possible to
ask
sure
i was wondering
with punt returns and kick returns is it
possible to
perhaps do expected yards
over expect sorry expected yards
uh sorry rushing yards over expected
and use the nfl
data that's available that they already
have from models before or
would we have to build ourselves
oh i i would i'm guessing
is mike lopez on he's probably a better
person to ask but i think it probably
yeah definitely that's a yeah go mike go
ahead yeah i think that your best two
steps zach are
the initial
expected rush yards on kaggle from the
2020 big data bowl that that framework
is there um i think probably more
aptly in terms of copying and pasting
code
um ben baldwin who tom mentioned earlier
he looked at using that same framework
with defensive coverage schemes so like
man versus zone
and i want to say his code is public
those are you those are your two best
bets i wouldn't be surprised if somebody
this year
goes and also replicates it
if you're trying to be that person
you know i think those two those two
places would be where to go
um
and get started there
thank you very much
of course
thank you i'll open it up to any other
remaining questions too
well thank you all so much for joining
and thank you tom that was amazing i
really appreciate your time and and
sharing all your insights with us
um i just a reminder we'll share all the
links and the recording up to the
rstudio youtube and on the meetup page
and on linkedin
but if you ever have any questions at
all or can't find something feel free to
reach out to me
um you can just email me rachel
rstudio.com
or on meetup in linkedin
thank you so much tom
thank you
thanks everyone for for listening today
have a great rest of the day everyone
[Music]